Vậy thôi, bình Việt tâm Anh và Vậy Nguy Kieu A&A số một của ốc cũng hợp tá phát triển công nghệ
í sinh tinh tiến A&A phòng cũng vào ưu phổi. Đại trực trang. Đé là lần đầu tiên, một vị Nguy Kieu
của Việt Nam đặt được phỏe tận hợp tá về công nghệ loại í sinh với Vậy Nguy Kieu
hàng đầu của ốc trên lia. Vậy A&A sẽ tục đại học Nhu yêu sau Wales.
Ót trên lia, kinh viên ốc ở ấy, nhóm các đại học Nhu yêu hàng đầu nước này. Nhanh
nguy Xin tăng tám năm nay y hú chăm hai mù sấu sự sự sinh kiến của tổng lãi sự
hợp đại học Nguy Kieu, bình Việt Nam tải sít đi. Vậy Nguy Kieu
hệ thống bệnh viện đã khoa tâm Anh và Vậy Nguy A&A đại học
điều sau Wales số một của ốc trên lia. Đại ký hợp tá cùng Nguy Kieu,
phát triển lên tảng í sinh tinh tiến và tiến năng bật nhất hiện nay là A&A.
Hứ hệnh mắc lại nhiều đu phá trong Nguy Kieu, sản sất thuốc, hoặc sinh
thì hiện mối trước mắt, Vậy Nguy Kieu A&A để rất hai hủ chương trình
chọc biển. Phát triển phóx sinh em ở A&A phòng cũng cho Việt Nam
và phát triển bẫu vắc sinh em ủng thư các thiệt hóa cho bệnh ủng thư
phổi hoặc đại trị trang. Giá chỉ của hợp tá không chỉ nhanh
tiếp nhận chuyển ra con nghệ như trước đây mà được phát ở
Vậy Nguy Kieu Kieu, bình sẽ cùng đấu tư nhân được và vật lực định
í cứu. Cùng tạo ra sử liệu và dài phát của hợp với đặc điểm
xu khai, bình tịch của con người. Trong đó có chút trong người Việt Nam và hủc đồng nằm
á, rau xưa bôn, giá nước Việt A&A đại học Nguy Kieu sau Wales
tìm từ hợp tác này sẽ là bị phòng bệnh tâm A&C dựng nên những thình công
mắn này cả chúng ta hiện giờ cũng cho thiệt hình dù hết. Nếu chúng ta
đầy Việt Nam chủ yếu tiếp cận các phóx sinh và thúc sinh
học phi công nghệ đã hoàn thiệt thì hợp tác dữ Việt Nam kiểu
tâm A&Tu hệ thống bệnh bị đặc hoa tâm A&N. Bối Việt A&A đại học
New South Wales mở ra trên trời mới khi các nhà khoa học trong nước,
con nghiên cứu công nghệ lỗi ngày từ gia đạn đầu, phát triển các phóx sinh và
thuốc mười an toàn hơn. Từng mất làm chủ công nghệ A&A,
cùng của A&N y tế cút xa và đồng có vào chủ đổi mười sẵn thạp y sinh tần câu.